welcome everyone um first of all i'd
like to
thank you for tuning in wherever you are
in the world and
and whatever time you're listening in
i'm welcome
i really appreciate you checking in and
at the same time i really hope that you
and your families are
safe during these challenging times my
name is imra varu and
i'm a medical scientist and a health
communication specialist
and for over eight years i've been doing
some very exciting research at the
intersection of inflammation and
coagulation more specifically focusing
on the role of extracellular traps
more specific even more specifically on
the neutrophil axis cell traps and how
they affect
the formation and and the dissolution
of blood clots and today i'm very
excited to
share some of the basic principles and
some of the basic learnings that
i've accumulated throughout these years
and and this is going to be an
introductory lecture about neutrophil
external traps and some of the exciting
pathways that that they that they cross
and some of the exciting
pathologies and and even physiologies
that they bring about in the human body
so i hope you'll enjoy this journey as
much as i do
and without further ado let's see what
we're going to discuss today
so as much as i would love to say that
you should stop me at any point if you
have questions and we can't do that this
time so
feel free to send me an email and i'll
be very happy to continue the discussion
at any point
so the first thing that we're going to
look through is a little bit talking
about the formation of extracellular
traps
a little bit defining what they are how
how they
are formed what forms do they have what
different types do they have
and also a little bit about their
structure and what they're composed of
then we're going to move on to
describing the physiological and the
pathological roles of these
extracellular traps
it's a huge task and it's impossible
within the limits of this time but
we'll dig into some interesting
physiological and pathological
aspects and in the third
part we're going to segue into
discussing the possible
and or already shown role of the
extracellular traps and some of the
implications of cobit 19
and infections and infection
complications and more general
that's what's ahead of us and let's
start with the first point let's talk a
little bit about extracellular traps
themselves
in order to do that let's just take a
step back here and
and imagine this cell that everyone
admires
it's called the polymorph morphonuclear
cell or
neutrophil the neutrophil is a round
shaped
cell that is that is found in the
circulation and many other many other
organs
it has this very specific nuclear
structure as you can see here on the
left
it's this trifold dumbbell shape very
condensed
chromatin packed structure that is in
the middle
and a bunch of granules with
mitochondria of course a lot
of cellular organelles inside and i
really want to focus on these two
components the
nucleus here and and the lots and lots
of granules that contain
all the good enzymes and all the good
antimicrobial proteins that
that the neutrophil has to offer and
we've known for
for quite a long time that if we start
stimulating the neutrophil with various
bacterial viral fungal or or even
cytokinal stimuli or neutrophils will
react
in in in a limited number of ways
the one thing they can do is they can go
through phagocytosis right
extracellular bacteria and fungi can be
captured through
phagocytosis this means that the
neutrophil will engulf
the pathogen and will digest it with
inside
inside its own cellular structure
we know them for we've known that for
quite a long time we also know that the
other pathway
classic and a classic classic pathway
that neutrophils can take
is degranulation as the release of their
enzymes into the extracellular space
and killing the microbes in the in the
surrounding area
and what is really exciting here is that
we've known the about these
mechanisms for quite some quite some
time now
and the the actual first microscopic
investigations of neutrophils by
mechnikov and ehrlich
they were carried out and as early as
the 19th century
and for over a hundred years we weren't
able to discover
a third way in which neutrophils are
able to kill pathogens and or demobile
destabilized pathogens and that is
through the formation of
neutrophil exosoda traps neutrophil
exocellular traps are a very exciting
structure it means that during the
formation of
of these structures the nuclear
structure
of the polymorph neutral cell cells
decondenses
it mixes with some of the granular
enzymes and then this whole
dna histone granular enzyme mix gets
catapulted
into the extracellular space they're
capturing and immobilizing bacteria
and this was hiding in plain sight for
over a hundred years
until arturo zizlinski and his lab in
2004 discovered that
that they exist so this is just a
beautiful
scanning electron microscopic image here
from one of our publications
and um really when you get to get the
joy of working with these structures
the first thing you realize about
neutrophil traps is that they are really
beautiful
you can you can see in the and the
scanning electron microscopic image here
on the left
uh this this kind of threaded structure
that has like 15 25 nanometers
nanometers in diameter uh it's it's
decorated with these granular proteins
uh histones presumably uh lstas and a
bunch of other
granular proteins and you can see how
they engulf not not only pathogens but
also cellular structures within the body
very very beautiful structures
and if you if you do an
immunohistochemistry you can see
with blue the dna web that is the
the backbone of the neutrophil excel
traps and you can see
the red dotted structures there are
histones attached to this
beautiful matrix besides being beautiful
they come in many flavors so there's not
only one type of neutrophil excel
traps soon after 2004 it has been
it it started to to become clearer and
clearer that there are
multiple pathways that lead to netosis
which is
the the cellular death-like pathway that
leads to
the formation of neutrophilic cell traps
or nets
so this netosis has at least three
different types but
probably way more than that the three
major types are depicted on this image
so
if we first look in the at the middle
arrow
uh we will see that if we stimulate
the neutrophil with certain agents and
certain triggers
such as pma for acetate and we wait
three to four hours in vitro which is
pretty pretty long
and what's going to happen is that the
nucleus decondenses
the granule the granular proteins start
mixing
with with the nucleus and then this
swollen
mix is getting exposed the membrane
ruptures in the extra cell and and
now the dna granular mix is now an
extracellular trap outside the cell
this is a true cell death if we look a
little bit higher than that
the first line the first arrow if we
follow that
we see an alternate version of net
formation this
version does not lead to a cell death
immediately this
leads to an a nucleotide cytoplast
formation
so in this case when we trigger netosis
with certain microbes
such as staphylococcus it has been shown
that netosis goes about in small chunks
instead of in one big burst and these
small chunks being released from time to
time
still allow the neutrophil to stay alive
and to stay functional even without
losing the full nuclear structure so
it's a very exciting
type of nethosis this one is called the
vital mitosis
vital metasis while the previous version
is called a suicidal mitosis which leads
to
that and the third one down here bottom
is is a very particular one is when
natural release is mediated by
mitochondrial dna
so these are mitochondrial mets which
are much rarer but
when we simulate eoxinophils for
instance
we can we can actually detect them
and if we take uh take a step back we
also recognize that that
neutrophil exercise traps are not the
only extracellular traps out there
neutrophils are not the only cells that
will go about this very specific release
of of dna into the extracellular space
so while in the first image it's a
beautiful neutrophil excess cell trap
from the wagner lab
in the next image you will see down here
if you stimulate macrophages with
candida albicans
we can see under certain circumstances
similar extracellular trap formation
this time it's a macrophage
ssl or trap or matte formation
another form of ets or xsl traps is when
we stimulate mast cells
in muscles it's already it's also been
shown and in this blood paper
cochlea is big by the end and colleagues
have shown that mast cells also undergo
xsl
trap formation under certain
circumstances as you can see in the
trypta staining we can also simulate
isinophils
in a way that they will release their
their access to their dna
and as i mentioned a couple of times uh
mitochondrial
netosis was detected in neozynophils
but what's even more interesting is that
it's not only
human cells and it's not only animal
cells that can
extrude their dna down here at the
bottom you will see
a paper in an image from a paper from
plant physiology from 2009
that and the the authors actually showed
that at the
very tip of the plant roots
there is some extracellular trap
formation that is
that is meant to defend the plant root
from infection if we if we give some
dnas in the mix and we start
uh enzymatically cutting off the
extracellular
the exotraps that surround the very tip
of the root
we will see that infections will have a
much more much higher propensity
of entering entering the plants the
very interesting mechanism that seems to
be conserved
around all eukaryotic
cells or at least certain eukaryotic
cell cell types
and of course i just wanted to
acknowledge the fact that
once someone starts talking about ets
the first thing that comes to mind is
the original et so i just wanted to give
a knot to that
it's a really hard task to to get all
the dna out from the cell
now i wanted to talk a little bit about
that because it's a really exciting part
of of the
mass formation story let's take a let's
focus on neutrophils here so if we if we
take a look at the
nuclear structure of the neutrophil we
will see it's a very compact
very wound up dna if you take a look at
the middle
of this image a little bit towards the
bottom you will see the coil
structure now how dna is spun around
histones and how the stones are holding
this very tight structure together
so the task here in order to loosen this
interaction up is to
loosen the interaction between histones
or the holding proteins
and dna now this is a very it's a very
simple charge-based react
interaction so to say histones are
generally positively charged
under intracellular ph and uh
and at the same time dna are and
negative the dna strands are negative
with charge so this is a
really uh tough a really strong
connection between the two
so how can we loosen this interaction
and how can the cell do that there are
multiple ways
if you look right above um the the
histones you will see something that
that in red
that is called path four that's peptidal
original the iminase
that is that was thought to be the whole
mark of
nato's is the hallmark enzyme of methods
for for long years
what this enzyme does is that it
converts peptidyl arginine
into peptidocitral and it cleaves in a
free a free ammonia
of this pathological chain thereby
reducing the positive charge
of histones now when we reduce that
the interaction loosens up and as you
can see upstream of that
this requires um in many instances
ros formation reactive oxygen species
formation which is
which is thought to be brought about uh
by
and and nadph oxidases upstream and the
signaling pathway that that leads to
this
uh loosening interaction so that's one
significant way of loosening the
interaction however
it it really became clear after a time
that pat four cannot be the only one to
do this
and if you lick if you if you look a
little bit to the right
in green you will see mpo
myeloperoxidase which is
again a hallmark of metals is a very
important enzyme that gets activated uh
during the process of mitosis and it's
able to
chlorinate histones and thereby also
hiding
some of their positive charges uh from
plain sight and
and that's that's another way of
loosening this interaction the third way
is if you look to the bottom you will
see that there's there's a possibility
to cleave histones proteolytically
and this proteolytic cleavage is brought
about by multiple enzymes but most
importantly
um it seems to be that neutrophil
allostates is the key player in this
mechanism neutrophil allostates which
which is originally in the granules it's
a very exciting enzyme
originally in the granules and during
degranulation it escapes the cell but
during net formation
it travels to the nucleus and starts
processing some of the histones
in order to help loosen this interaction
so there are multiple ways to loosen
this interaction
there are multiple ways to to get there
and and start thinking about catapulting
dna
um but that's this
this um these multiple ways can also be
summarized in a different way now i know
that the worst thing that a presenter
can do
is to put a table like this in in the
presentation so i'm really not going to
spend much time
on it what i wanted to highlight here is
that today it's clear that different
triggers go through different pathways
that lead to different
that lead to different types of of
loosening of this interaction
if we look at the very top line you will
we will see that pma
which is a very very widely used
in vitro trigger for nato's at least
used to be does not require a path for
in its pathway it's necessarily this
pathway well as jonomycin does not
require nadh oxidase right below that
right and if we go through the different
triggers we see that these
different and netosis pathways are
requiring different components
so now that we talked a little bit about
the formation about the different
forms of netosis of let's let's take a
look at
what these structures actually meant to
do and it's a harder question than it
seems
in 2004 when they were discovered
everyone
thought that that the mere function of
the ventricular axis of traps is
literally to trap bacteria and trap
extracellular pathogens
and they seem to be designed to do that
nets are really
sticky if you work with them in the
liver it's like it's really like these
sticky spider webs that stick to
everything so it was really not a
surprise to see bacteria
here here probably it's sugar clay um
being trapped um on the left from the
original digilenski paper
soon it became apparent that that it can
also entrap
viral agents such as hiv as this
clever page from cell
shows and if we take a if we take a
closer look at what what
really is inside these nets and what the
constituents are it's really not
surprising that
that they're that they're doing so well
in their laboratory circumstances and
in capturing and sometimes even killing
bacteria it's full of histones right and
histones
in the uh we think about the histones as
these um
these holder structures for dna but once
they're externalized once they're in the
extracellular space histones become
become a real weapon for uh for innate
immunity
histones released in circulation and
histories in the tissues if they meet
bacteria
fungi and other pathogens what they
supposedly do is they form pores uh in
those membrane structures and they're
very efficient killers and killer
pathogen clarions
of course they're a double-edged sword
they're not 100 specific to
bacteria and pathogens so in the next uh
instances we'll we'll see some of the
detrimental effects of that but histones
are very potent in
in killing bacteria and other pathogens
we also have a bunch of allostates and
other another
syrian parity is also cathepsin um as
another protease um
embedded in nets which are again very
efficient in cleaving certain material
proteins
we also have myeloperoxidase which is
able to chlorinate and
and and inactivate certain bacterial
components and we have the actual
defensings ll-37 and other
anti-microbial proteins
that also play a role so it seems that
nets are really well-suited
to to capture pathogens there's an
ongoing debate whether they all they
they whether they actually kill
pathogens as well
it seems in certain instances they're
able to do that in certain instances
they only able to immobilize pathogens
and there are some rare instances where
uh where something different happens
when certain pathogens are able to kind
of
live within nets and and form some sort
of
biofilm-ish structure or or
community uh within nets but that that
seems to be
the the rare case so that's what we
think
um this is the originally thought
that's dead but as we alluded to that
already
they can be really detrimental to the
host and it soon became
clear that nets are a pathogenic
component of a host of known diseases
it doesn't necessarily make them the
cause of these diseases but
if we look at a range of diseases from
autoimmune diseases to lung disease to
cancer
nets have been detected since 2004 and
this is really just a high level
summary of all those uh pathological
conditions that nets participate in
on the on the very left you will see
that um
it's mainly mediated by histones but
nets are not only detrimental to
bacterial cells
as we already mentioned they are also
detrimental to certain tissue cells if
they're
if they get out of control within the
tissue they can cause tissue damage
a delay in tissue repair this is
especially important in
in healing diabetic wounds where the
wagner lab already
showed that that if nets are present
which are more likely to be present in
diabetic patients because
hyperglycemia makes neutrophils more
more susceptible to net formation
than the presence of gnats actually
inhibits wound healing as well
in certain circumstances um they can
they have all
already been shown in in the
pathogenesis of sepsis
uh and all the immunity a host of
autoimmune diseases
the very first candidate and and the
very actively researched um
pathogenic kind of component of kind of
disease was it was sle
systemic liposuction uh for use we
we really had no idea why anti-dna and
anti-double-stranded dna
type would form and in what way would
they form inside and we know we detect
that in patient and we know it's
it's one of the one of the pathological
findings in the disease but we have had
really no idea what
what the uh what the substrate for the
formation of those antibodies
uh was and when nets were discovered
sure he
actively exposed uh dna strands
uh on on his toes then then suddenly uh
this
became the in the center of the center
of attention because
they seem to be an explanation for
how the immune cells could actually
sense and start
forming antibodies against a
double-stranded dna so that
that that is uh that is also something
that has been actively researched if we
if we take a step to the right
we can see that if if nets interact with
macrophages
it the macrophages are activated
disagreements are looking one beta
and that leads to a range of chronic
inflammations such as ethers
it can propose atherosclerosis tumor
associated
inflammation and then certain organ
damages in cancer and ischemia or
perfusion injury
then in the third step we can take a
look in the middle
but we'll see what happens if nets get
released to the
uh to the circulation now anyone who has
worked with blood
and serum knows that that
can imagine that if such a sticky such a
highly charged
web-like structure gets in the
circulation
that can't really go well and that's
what really happens
nets if they appear in the circulation
they lead to
vassal occlusion very quickly they
hyperstimulate coagulation they inhibit
the dissolution of clots
and they can really really quickly lead
to to severe thrombosis
and now actually today we think that and
that nets are present in both arterial
and venous thrombosis
and also in certain forms of capillary
thrombosis we're going to talk about
this a little bit
in more detail in the upcoming slides on
the right
you can see that net formation has been
detected in certain tumor
progressions uh in in tumor beds and
also
um enabling tumor cells to to stick to
um to a certain tissue and and to
proliferate and therefore um they have
been
a candidate and and a candidate player
in matters disease formation
we can see how nets can trigger into and
auto antibody formation
and also how they interplay with the
with the um complement system to
to work together towards the formation
of gout
so these are just really um this is
really just a cherry picked selection of
of of diseases and pathological
conditions in which nets play a role
uh let's just zoom in in the middle here
now let's let's talk a little bit about
this
very exciting interaction of net
formation and blot code formation
now today we know that this is a two-way
interaction
if we take a look at the left and take a
look at the bottom
this image depicts an injured
endothelial
endothelium and and let's say in a in a
capillary system
when this injury happens neutrophils
well neutrophils
will be uh will be drawn to that to that
part of
the endothelium and neutrophils can
actually go through an activation
through this endothelial damage that
will cause this
this octopus-like structure to appear
which is now which is which is how nets
are depicted on this image
once nets appear in the circulation
multiple things go
go hayward so one thing we know is that
dna which is the backbone of
of nets is a very very potent um
trigger for for coagulation for the
namely for the
intrinsic pathway of coagulation his
stones themselves are able
if we look in the middle and the top
we'll see that histones are able to
activate platelets through toll-like
receptors
activated platelets they will stick to
formula burn factor released from the
engine and
from the injured endothelium and
platelets will also right surface for
the coagulation
factors to build together once that
process gets going
the polyphosphate also gets secreted
from platelets which
further triggers the intrinsic pathway
of coagulation
and as the coagulation factors build up
it all ends up in the fiber information
which you can see on the right side
um this half staggered dumbbell shaped
structure
formation and and fibrin is really what
holds
holds blood clots together so once
fibrin appears in the circulation
fibrin starts capturing cells further
platelets
further sulfur red blood cells and this
mash work this combined meshwork of nets
bomb deliverance factor and also fibrin
this trifecta is what we think
is really really really trim both we
used to focus uh we used to focus on
fibrin
and for really really long years we
thought of fibrin as the primary
scaffold
of trombi but now we know that there are
at least two other scaffolds and thrombi
that hold
from by another block clause together
and and these are from blubbering factor
released from the damaging endothelium
and neutrophil axis so traps released
from neutrophils
so if we take a look at just once again
a beautiful image of nutribullet cell
traps this fine threaded structure
and we compare it with with fibrin with
fibrin and what fibrin looks like in
vitro
we can see some similarities fibrin is
generally thicker so to say on average
um it's um it's it's more like in the up
in
the 100 nanometer region or so say 50 to
150 nanometer in diameter
uh whereas whereas nets are a way
thinner
nets are always decorated with proteins
fibrin in vitro is
just pure pure strands but it's really
the
the combined meshwork of these two bones
that
that brings us to clot formation and
one thing to mention here is that
pathogens already
know this and we and we and we have to
remind ourselves that that the pathogens
already know those pathogens
are equipped to not only cleave fibrin
which is the primary scaffold and trauma
but also to cleave
nets and if we think back to the example
it's a very interesting example of what
uh what what's what's streptococci do
streptococci release
streptokinase which is an activator of
the uh
of the plasminogen plasmid system which
will eventually cleave fibrin
and and lead to clot dissolution at the
same time
streptodornase is synthesized in the
same streptococci
and streptornase is a dnase so why would
someone have a dnase
right next to the right next to an
enzyme that that is able to
eventually lead to the cleavage of
fibrin well the reason
probably as i think today is that these
two processes
netosis and thrombosis they are together
they they work together when
when capturing bacteria in the
circulation so this image really depicts
that
that the notion of immunothrombosis
where a pathogen comes in the system the
pathogen activates nutritional trap
formation
and as soon as nutrition traps during
the circulation they start
triggering fibrin formation so we know
that some of the pathogens
or have already tried to to come to to
overcome this double barrier
right with with the combined synthesis
of fibrin cleavage and dna cleavage
enzymes
and it's so true that for years when
streptokinase was identified as as a
potential medication and it was really
hard to purify
it and really hard to clean all the
streptodornate off of it
and years later we think back and we say
maybe we shouldn't have
maybe we should have kept those things
together because pathogens
knew better what was inside the thrombus
than we knew at that time
so interesting to think about that in
that from that perspective
and this really segues into our last
last topic of discussion here which is
just how and what role if any
uh unusual xsl traps and rxl traps
themselves play in in cobit 19.
and here a lot of the data comes from
preliminary studies
preliminary observations there's a bunch
of pre-print material online it's really
hard
at this point to say something but what
we can definitely think of
is all the different pathways that nets
can
can possibly influence we know from
previous infections and we know from
previous pathogenetic kind of pathways
that net formation can contribute to a
ards that accurate respiratory distress
syndrome which is very
severe it leads to very severe lung
damage and and respiratory dysfunction
and we know that in influenza for
instance when
ards happens nets are there in the
pathogenesis
so that's a that's definitely a
candidate pathway
if you look at if you look at the top
circle here you can also see mucus
formation
and mucus accumulation the reason it's
there is that because we know that in
cystic fibrosis patients
who have this chronic condition and
genetically inherited condition that
leads to mucous
accumulation that neutrophils and and
the total neutrophils are also there in
that mucus
and we know that that strep that that
dnases
um inhaling dna just helps uh helps the
quality of life for these patients so
uh so we're also focusing on that when
we talk about code
19 it's it's a candidate that then that
that might that's might be my paleo role
in mucus formation
on the on the left we can see
atherosclerosis which is more more like
a long-term complication
um that that coicoin 193 netosis might
lead to
and down here um at the at the very
bottom
uh we will see thrombosis which we
already talked about how nets
might contribute to thrombosis it's an
especially uh especially exciting part
of kobit 19 pathogens because we do
know that there is microtrombus
formation
in in the vessels of uh and in certain
pulmonary vessels
you will see and you will appreciate in
this publication from from lapkisson
and colleagues from this subset of of
landsat that they identified that in
cobit 19
lungs they actually these lungs are
actually filled with capillaries
that are filled with thrombi that
contain nets
and this is especially in severe covet
19 down here and
the in the second panel at the bottom
you will see that dna is stained with
red
while citrulline the histones are
stained with green you can see that
these tremble are really rich in
citrullinated histones which are
there a hallmark of that formation so we
know that there is some methodic
activity and
and the vascular complications of in
these patients
and just a trigger warning so the next
image is is going to be
um it's going to be about a patient who
actually goes through
a thrombosis not in the lungs but in the
periphery
so um just look away for a second if
um that's that that's too much but this
is the site that some of
some of the intensive intensive care
unit doctors see
uh this skin this can coe can can cause
in 16 of the cases actually according to
a study can cause a trauma
complications only in the lungs but only
also her system so
it's really something to think about and
really to to watch
closely okay image is gone so now you
can look again
and just just comparison the 16 might
sound you know might sound
a lot or might sound you know just just
a little but
with influence from both the
complications uh are around four point
three four point six
percent so it's definitely a higher
propensity
for uh thrombotic complications in copay
19 patients of course of course that
that that that puts nets in
a highly suspicious position there's
already a proposed mechanism of how
thrombosis and microcapillaries and and
and other vasculature can form
if you take a look at the left side here
this is just really a proposed mechanism
of how
cobit 19 how starscope 2 can attach to
epithelial
surfaces through the ace2 receptors
that will get internalized and then that
will lead to
tissue down damage and damps uh and
these dams will
these associated molecular patterns well
damage associated molecular patterns
will lead to
a trigger into triggering that ptosis
and this triggered netosis
will lead to further organ damage and
and if this epithelial surface happens
to be like within the vasculature then
this will lead to to thrombosis again
this is
this is just a model as of yet but what
we do know
from measurements from from covid sierra
actually is that covet patients do seem
to have elevated levels of net markers
what are some of the net markers first
you will see cf dna which is cell free
dna
which really means that that these
patients have a have a lot of dna
a much higher concentration of dna and
in their
in their serum than than healthy
individuals do
however cf dna cell dna is not really
specific to netosis it can come from
necrosis and
a bunch of other conditions what is more
specific is citrullinated h3 just
related histone type 3
which which shows that there was some
pad activity
somewhere and that that led to the
formation of that citrinated histone
and at the same time mpo dna complexes
myeloperoxidase dna complexes were also
detected
which we already talked about how
important that mpo is in in the process
so that these two markers are more
specific to mitosis and these were
elevated and i'm in
a small study on our 50-something
patients uh but it's a very important
finding
and what's also um uh interesting in
this
and the same study is that uh the coping
19 patients
sera themselves induced netosis
and in vitro under in vitro conditions
so
they're definitely there they're
definitely there in the vascular
complications
but we will continue to to be on the
lookout
in terms of of of where nats can pla
might play more of a role in cobit 19
complications
so with all that said what we achieved
today in this short time is we discussed
various ways of net formation right we
talked about
suicidal mitosis we talked about
mitochondrial netosis
uh we we also talked about uh the
another way which is called vital
mitosis and we also talked about the
exercise transformation in general
how mast cells is in a fills even plant
cells are capable of
of formation we also describe the role
of
of these extracts in immunity and and
various pathological conditions
really high level from sle to uh to even
from bosus and that's how we segued into
a copied 19 complications
and how we examined some of the existing
research out there
so of course there are many many people
um i'd like to thank who
who's whose work was included in here
and really
bits and pieces and people who i've
worked with
together over the years at samuel vice
university uh
my my mentor in christmas collab at
harvard medical school
my excellent mentor denise wagner at the
national institute of biological
standards and control in the uk
uh where where i was able to spend some
time with an embo fellowship at the
calling along staff who
provided invaluable input to some of
this research
fulbright scholarship and and and and
many many others who
uh who helped me do some research in
this in this exciting area
so with that said i would i would like
to thank you for your attention
and the last thing i have here is a
little riddle
we've talked about nets and what they
look like
and how fibular they are and we also
talked about fibrin a lot of times and
we know how these two work together in
in thrombus formation and in
immunothrombosis
so i'd really like to take a stab at
which one this could be
is this a neutral galaxy cell trap or is
this a
fibrin and you will have three two
one seconds to guess that is actually
neater
it's a frozen lake it's one of my
favorite images ever
thank you for your attention and i would
love to continue the discussion here's a
link to my
linkedin and also an email address thank
you so much for tuning in